hey 42 here Japan is a land of tradition
it's a country where ancient Customs are
revered but Japan also has a long
history of embracing Cutting Edge ideas
and Technologies like toilets that shoot
water directly at your scoten and
vending machines that sell well yeah
that's a bit of a contradiction isn't it
how can a country that's so deeply
rooted in Tradition be one of the most
technologically advanced on Earth well
the truth is that Japan's evolution from
a feudal society as recently as the 19th
century to a global economic Powerhouse
come the 20th century is actually one of
the most remarkable stories in human
history if you need an example of how
eagerly Japan can Embrace a technology
when it wants to look no further than
the digital camera although an American
invention Japan quickly snapped it up
and monopolized the market the likes of
which I don't think I've seen in any
other consumer tech product Sony
Japanese Canon Japanese nickon Japanese
Fujifilm Japanese Panasonic Japanese
Olympus Japanese Pentax Japanese anyway
you get the picture sorry although
arguably Japan's technological export
game peaked in 1958 when they invented
instant Ramen Oodles of Noodles in a cup
in an instant screw the digital camera
that's the Pinnacle of human achievement
right there and all of this from Japan a
country that only opened its doors to
the outside world in 1853 at about the
same time steam trains were first
gaining Traction in
Britain now just a quick warning that
this is going to be a difficult video
for me it's all about a technology that
we invented then decided to be so
utterly crap had come the 21st century
that almost everyone else now does it
better anyway what was it that suddenly
catapulted the nation of Japan from a
feudal society to a technological
superpower seemingly
overnight the answer is simple a
revolution a Revolution catalyzed by a
single technology that changed
everything a technology that in the
space of a few decades broke down
seemingly insurmountable barriers and
connected what were previously Out Of
Reach intellectual minds and financial
hubs and the
result Japan exploded humbly making a
mockery of the rest of the world in the
process this is the fascinating story of
the shinh kanen the Japanese bullet
train the opening of Japan's first
Railway line in 1872 represented a
welcome sign of progress but the trains
were slow and unreliable and the steam
engine frequently broke down leaving
passengers stranded for hours at a time
as Japan grew in the first half of the
20th century more and more railway lines
were being built but the issues that
plag the first train stuck around by the
1950s the average speed of a Japanese
train was a poultry 36 M an hour and it
wasn't uncommon for a trip from Tokyo to
Osaka a distance of just 300 mil to take
over 7 hours and the infrastructure made
no sense either tracks often followed
the winding course of rivers rather than
the shortest distance between two cities
meaning trains were constantly slowing
down to weave their way around
BS by this point the first cars and
aeroplanes had already arrived in Japan
and overnight the populace came to favor
them over the sluggish trains however in
1958 the country was preparing to host
the Olympic Games and Japan was Keen to
show the world that it had evolved
significantly since the end of the
second world war and was now a Modern
Nation capable of hosting the most
prestigious sporting event on the planet
but their embarrassing Grail system
didn't exactly shout progress so in 1959
the Japanese government solidified plans
for their first ever high-speed Railway
line the project would cost more than
Jeff bezos's divorce actually nothing
cost that much but at an estimated 200
billion yen about1 billion it would be
pricey however the government was
willing to spend big this was about more
than just getting people from A to B
this was a statement a reaffirmation to
the world that yes Japan had been
defeated but it was now ready to rise
again From the Ashes as a phoenix a sexy
metal train shaped
[Music]
Phoenix but to pullis off the shinkansen
engineers would have to innovate in
quite a few ways for a start unlike
other train systems which often share
tracks with slower local trains the
shinkansen would operate on its own
dedicated routes moreover these tracks
were engineered with banked turns
allowing the train to maintain its
blistering speed even through curves
they weren't building a railway they
were building a goddamn roller
coaster to enhance the smoothness of the
ride the tracks employed continuous
welded rails traditionally tracks were
short segment bolted together which
incidentally is the primary cause of the
all too familiar click clack
noise the shin consen seamless tracks
meant less friction which meant higher
speeds which meant less maintenance and
when your entire country is prone to
sporadic Godzilla attacks having to fix
stuff less often is a
godsend to ensure the shinkansen will be
stable at such high speeds it was
necessary for the existing Cape gauge
tracks at 3' 6 in wide to be beefed up
to what we now call standard gauge at a
girthy 4' 8 1/2 in level Crossings were
eliminated too Bridges were utiliz
frequently along the Route so cars don't
have to slow down for trains and vice
versa rather than coil sprad Springs the
shinen used a revolutionary airspring
suspension system to increase comfort
and stability and of course the shinen
was given an iconically massive pointy
nose it looked like pure science fiction
in the 60s and it was a Hallmark of
aerodynamic design meticulously crafted
to minimize air resistance and to
suppress tunnel Boom the loud booming
noise created when a train enters a
tunnel at High
Velocity they even created a special
diagnostic train nicknamed Dr yellow
this bright yellow Rolling Stock is
equipped with special sensors to monitor
the condition of the tracks below and
the overhead wires all so that fals iner
Network can be detected as quickly and
efficiently as possible and all these
efforts paid off the fastest steam train
in Japan at the time topped out at 60
MPH and the first shinson Railway now
known as the taido line had a top speed
of 130 mph more than double that might
not sound particularly fast by today's
standards but it was a game changer for
the people of Japan it slashed the
average Journey time from Tokyo to Osaka
to Just 4
hours we've got a train that takes
longer than that in England and it only
goes toing Wigan then in 1975 the Sano
shinkansen extension line was built
connecting Tokyo all the way to
fukoka you could now go from
fukoka to Tokyo a distance of 680 mi in
just 5 hours without changing trains the
people of fukoka thought this was fuking
brilliant but the success of the Shinken
wasn't just due to the massive reduction
in Journey times they were also
remarkably reliable something that
couldn't be said for their conventional
cousins a railway line is like a Choose
Your Own Adventure book every few miles
there's a point where the train can go
one way or the other and just like in a
Choose Your Own Adventure book making
the wrong choice can mean the difference
between getting to work on time or
ending up naked in a swamp with your ear
being more by a horny a if a train
passes a junction and follows the wrong
track the driver can't simply pull a
U-turn the train will have to keep going
until it reaches the next station at
which point it can change tracks and go
back the way it came in order to avoid
schedule deviations which were plaguing
conventional train lines the shinin sent
were equipped with an automated system
called centralized traffic control that
allowed them to seamlessly navigate even
the most complex Junctions without
having to slow down for a second
together with a second automated safety
system called automatic Train control
ATC also developed for the shinkansen
the system could automatically slow down
any train on the network depending on
the speed of the trains ahead or behind
it and intervene If a driver fails to
respond to hazards in time now contrary
to popular belief the original Shinken
trains never actually
levitated that requires something called
magl technology which has only been
employed in real life sporadically over
the years usually for very short
Journeys like airport shuttles most
notably the Shanghai magav was opened in
2004 offering top speeds of 270 mph
although to be honest the Shanghai
maglev is completely bloody useless it
only covers a distance of 19 mil over 7
and 1/2 minutes which is impressive but
it means that by the time it reaches
full speed in the middle of its Journey
it has to start slowing down again as a
result it averages a speed of 155 mph
slower than a non magev high-speed train
I guess this is what happens when a
country has too much disposable income
anyway despite not levitating the
original shinkansen trains were designed
specifically to minimize friction and
vibration in every way so they could
Glide along the tracks like us say Bal
with a greas to
pass even though the trains were
traveling at 130 mph you could balance a
coin on its Edge and it wouldn't fall
over passengers could place cups of teas
on the window l in ack knowledge they
wouldn't spill this might seem rather
mundane to us today but back in the' 60s
it was as if the laws of physics had
been
Rewritten further construction of the
shinkansen network was rapid now there
are nine individual but interconnected
shinkansen lines and Counting connecting
the entire country all the way from
saporo in the north to kagoshima in the
South with the fastest train in Japan
now cruising at a speedy 200
mph
today the average delay for a shinen
train is less than 1 minute and that
includes delays caused by natural
disasters to put that into perspective a
British train being delayed by less than
one minute is rarer than seeing a
unicorn gold coins inside a
weather spoons and that's because our
trains are so old the tracks are made
from the bones of Victorian children
speaking of natural disasters shinin
sent lines are fitted with earthquake
detection systems which can
automatically cut power to trade
if early warning signs had detected of a
potentially dangerous earthquake which
is nice to know I guess the implications
of the Shinken went beyond convenience
economically cities that were connected
by the shinkansen experienced
unprecedented growth from Osaka to ngoya
to harashima it was like a game of
Monopoly where everyone wins and you
don't spend four hours threatening to
murder your family for not selling you
Mayfair furthermore the shinkansen
revolutionized the way people lived and
worked families no longer had to uproot
for job opportunities someone could work
in Tokyo but choose to live in a quieter
City like shizuka and commute daily such
a concept was Unthinkable before the
shinen and the effects rippled around
the globe Japan had taken a billion
pound Gamble and pretty much placed it
all on a single train system and boy did
it pay off transforming it from a broken
postwar economy to being the third
richest country on the freaking planet
and that's enough to make all the other
countries stand up and take notice the
shinkansen success story inspired the
construction of similar High-Speed Rail
systems like the tgv in France the a in
Spain Germany's ice and many more
freeletter acronym inclined Nations but
it can be argued that none have managed
to emulate the success of the
shinin you see there are now faster
trains out there sure but speed was
never the primary goal of shinin Sen's
design it was capacity it was designed
to move large numbers of people very
quickly this is a small country with 125
million people and it has the world's
largest city and today during peak times
a high-speed train departs from Tokyo
every 3
minutes every single day about a quarter
of a million people ride the shinkansen
in Japan also after 50 years of
continuous operation and over 10 billion
passengers the shinkansen has never had
a sing single fatal accident officially
making it the world's safest train
system and now Japan is once again
looking to the Future as it always has
done new lines are being developed using
superconducting magv technology like in
Shanghai which promises speeds of up to
mph when complete the Cho shinkansen
will be the longest magv route in the
world and a trip from Tokyo to Osaka
will take a breathtaking 607 for
minutes the primary driving force behind
the Inception of the first ever shinkin
Cent was a humble engineer hios Shima an
employee of Japanese national Railways
who was intensely passionate about the
future of trains and their core role in
public mass transit he had a vision and
fortunately his government listened to
him so you see Des shinen was never just
a train and it was never about speed or
World leading safety or having shiny new
toys to show off it was a symbol a
symbol of Japan's resilience Innovation
and vision it was about saying this is
what's possible when government funds
are put into projects that make sense
for and directly benefit the people
rather than vanity projects designed to
win
elections personally I think most
countries can learn a lesson or two from
this humble electric train because the
bullets train
well and truly shot Japan into the 21st
century and
beyond thanks for
watching